if you had to watch your biggest enemy
[ __ ] the girl of your dreams in order
for you to marry her would you do it
absolutely not like that is like one
part of me that is so irish and insecure
i can't handle the idea of another guy
[ __ ] my wife properly you know what i
mean like i can't i can't allow her to
know what else is out there i've
convinced her that this is satisfactory
and it's it's it's it's a miraculous
magic trick that i've pulled off but i
can't i can't give her one shot and then
she's like oh i don't like even though i
signed the contract we've been dating on
and off since we're 10 years old
literally we're neighbors that whole
thing it is not psychotic we both have
had hpv at one point in our lives
and uh and have probably cycled it back
and forth through each other but uh
it's uh yeah no it would be i would not
want to be her only thing she uh she
actually had a black boyfriend which i
was super proud of
because i'm still filling her up so that
feels pretty good